hello hello this is Adam Smith calling
from nobelprize.org the website of the
Nobel Prize in Stockholm is this
professor Allison yes yes yes sorry you
guys have so much hope probably many
many congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize oh well thank you thank you
so much just two out of Anniston dream
of a lifetime I don't know what to say I
understand how did the news actually
reach you I saw some reporter called out
it's faster yourselves I'm Sweden Sweden
in my son calls startup TV your son must
be pretty happy too yeah amazing area
I'm still shocked it's the first prize
award is specifically for a cancer
therapy for many years and that's a nice
hopeful thing for everybody that it's
something to a reward yes I think that's
correct
living hopeful continue adore to try to
get good as they go better patients I
mean you didn't actually set out to find
a cure for cancer this was a this was
basically no no I was trying I was
trying to understand how key smells
works in fact figure out this one thing
was a you know this negative regulator
had this idea that if we just took that
off you know maybe it would do a better
job of killing cancer cells sure now if
it works yet again an example of not
knowing which way research is going to
take you yep you know a basic scientist
but I have to say you do sound excited
it's nice what speechless kind of
thinking you know yeah yeah what your
friends found out came to the hotel room
you know therapy conference in New York
City
so people are joining you in your hotel
room yes yes you're assembling a party
around you people heard about it showing
up spontaneous celebration a little
champagne that's that sounds pretty good
and I have to mention that I've actually
heard you playing the harmonica at them
you know therapy
right which is checkpoints yeah I I do
hope you plan to bring your harmonica to
Stockholm when you come in December I'm
breathing outbreak I was wondering
whether I was brave enough to ask you to
play on the telephone now I think you
should play oh good it's a pleasure to
speak to you and we greatly look forward
to welcoming you to Stockholm when you
come okay well thank you thank you thank
you so much and that's a nice again
thanks thank you so much